the avengers have assembled and the game
lets you play as kamala khan
the hulk iron man black widow thor and
captain america
but who should you choose we're here to
help you decide by breaking down
each hero's fighting style kamala khan
aka miss marvel is the first hero you'll
spend time with in the campaign
and she's the most well-rounded of the
bunch kamala is a formidable fighter
both up close
and at range her super-sized punches are
great for getting up close and personal
and her special attacks like hi5 offer
solid crowd control
knocking enemies back at a distance she
can sling a stretchy arm at enemies in
the air
an attack you can spam without fear of
running out of ammo
or charge what's more kamala's polymorph
ability
automatically dodges enemy attacks as
she stretches around their punches and
lasers
her ultimate and biggin transforms her
into a giant even stretchier version of
herself
letting you turn the tables on all those
bad guys finally she can heal herself
and nearby allies
if you want a well-balanced hero you can
pick up easily
kamala is your girl this probably comes
as no surprise but hulk is the avengers
most
in your face fighter he might move the
slowest but he makes up for it with very
powerful melee strikes
hulk can instantly take one standard
enemy out of the fight by picking them
up and using them as a living weapon
loki's style his special attacks are
great for crowd control
thunderclap in particular is a useful
way to clear out a gang of enemies in
front of you
hulk's rage ability lets you stay in the
fight longer as you deal rage damage you
actually recover
health if you want to charge into battle
and not stop throwing punches until it's
over
hulk is for you hulk smash and you can
too
iron man is basically the polar opposite
of the hulk tony stark prefers to hover
above the action and rain down repulsor
beams from above
his moveset is very technical making him
one of the more advanced characters to
master
you'll need to recharge your long range
beams by throwing punches
so expect to do a lot of dodging and
countering while you're on the ground
from the air he can control the
battlefield with his unibeam
melting down the heavier enemies his arc
overload ability also lets him fire from
above without having to land and
recharge
if you want to stay in the sky and
support your teammates iron man is the
one to pick
black widow is the fastest hero on the
team and probably the best option for
one-on-one fights
her ultimate called power surge gives
her charged up batons to beat down ames
robots and mass
but for the most part she focuses on
grappling them one by one
she quite literally carries a grappling
hook which you can use to interrupt
enemy attacks and get right up in their
face
her abilities let her stun a target or
go invisible letting you weave in and
out of the crowd as you pick your target
if you want to focus on individual bad
guys rather than an overall view of the
battlefield
black widow is a good bite
time for a prison break just as iron man
is a technical character to play
thor's combination of flight hammer hits
and mighty magic
also makes him a tricky one to master
but where iron man dives into the battle
to take a break from firing above
thor is more suited to charging straight
into the fight taking to the skies when
you need a breather
even his ultimate which teleports him
through the bifrost is designed to give
you a break as you decide where on the
battlefield he reappears in a burst of
norse energy
mjolnir deals heavy damage to your foes
whether you're up in their face or
throwing it from afar
and thor's abilities unleash bursts of
energy that can damage whole groups of
bad dudes
thor can also activate odin force to
keep himself from taking damage while he
attacks with lightning-charged attacks
thor is a well-balanced fighter with
melee ranged and aerial options
just be prepared for some more technical
play finally there's captain america
he's the leader of the group and as such
his abilities can help support the rest
of the team in combat
his rally cry lowers enemy defenses
letting your squad deal extra damage to
anyone who gets marked
steamroller meanwhile stuns enemies as
your shield bounces all around and
strikes targets
of course steve can also pummel his
enemies with punches or throw his mighty
shield from afar
his ultimate will also get him nice and
buffed for some melee combat
if you want to help the team deal damage
while throwing some solid punches
yourself
cap is your man so hopefully this video
helps you decide which hero is right for
you
all six of the avengers have very
different play styles but that's exactly
why they work as a team
spider-man hawkeye and kate bishop are
on the way too so expect them to mix up
the dynamics even more
stay tuned to gamespot for more avengers
coverage including our full review
coming soon
[Music]
you